hey everyone welcome to this session
today's topic is the top 10 cyber
security threats and how to tackle them
also make sure to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
now let's get started let's have a look
at today's agenda
we will start off with what is a
cybersecurity threat
then move on to the different types of
cyber threats faced in today's times and
finally end the session by understanding
how we can
prevent cyber attacks
before i begin let me talk about a few
real life scenarios
in 2018 and 2019 the famous american
multinational coffee and donut company
dunkin donuts
announced that it had been a victim of a
cyber attack
it stated that it was a case of
credential stuffing attack
in such an attack user's credentials are
stolen
in this case hackers used user
credentials leaked at other sites to
gain entry to the dunkin donuts perks
rewards accounts
the type of information available inside
such an account
includes a user's first and last names
email address
a 16-digit dd perks accounts number and
a dd perks qr code
here the hackers targeted the account
itself which they could then sell on
dark web forums
in order to prevent such attacks in the
future dunkin donuts asked its customers
to set unique passwords that are not
repeated
that was all about the cyber attack
dunkin donuts witnessed
just like how the code 19 situation is
affecting various domains
it is also adversely affecting
cybersecurity
interpol states that attackers are
attacking computer networks and systems
of businesses individuals and big global
organizations
due to the shift of focus to the kovit
crisis cyber security is taking a huge
brunt
even who has stated that from the
beginning of this pandemic it has
witnessed a sky-high increase in the
number of cyber attacks
there are fake emails doing the rounds
in which scammers are impersonating w
head show
reports also state that the financial
services sector is increasingly being
targeted during the covet 19 coronavirus
pandemic
various banks and financial institutions
have witnessed a spike in the number of
cyber attacks in the last few months
several banks are increasing cyber
attack awareness amongst their customers
and also asking them not to disclose any
confidential information
to a third party now that we have an
idea as to how cyber attacks can affect
us let's go ahead and understand the
meaning of a cyber threat
a cyber threat is a warning which allows
you to prepare against a cyber attack
when there is an unauthorized access by
a third party to your system and network
it is termed as a cyber attack
the person who carries this out is
termed as a hacker or an attacker or a
cyber criminal
a possibility of such an attack is
termed as a cyber threat
as we saw previously cyber attacks lead
to data breaches which result in either
data manipulation or loss of highly
confidential data
it also results in financial losses and
which in turn has a colossal impact on
the businesses
in addition to these losses lot of
companies face reputational damages as
well
trust plays a vital role when it comes
to customer relationships
cyber attacks can hamper an
organization's reputation
and erode the customers trust let's now
get an understanding of the most common
cyber attacks
here we will look into the top 10 cyber
threats in today's times
first up we have the malware attack
this is a very common form of cyber
attack the term malware refers to
malicious software
virus including spyware worms ransomware
adware and trojans
trojan virus is a form of malware that
disguises itself as a legitimate
software
ransomware blocks access to the key
components of the network
whereas spyware as the name suggests is
a software that steals your confidential
data without your knowledge
coming to adware it is also a software
but this software displays advertising
content such as banners or pop-ups on a
user screen
marvel breaches a network through a
vulnerability
it usually happens when the victim
clicks a dangerous link or downloads an
email attachment or also when an
infected pen drive is used
let's now have a look at the ways in
which we can prevent a malware attack
first and foremost you should use any
kind of an antivirus software
this step might be something that you
have heard time and again but it is a
very effective way to prevent a malware
attack
antivirus software is a program that can
protect your computer against the above
mentioned viruses
this data security utility installed on
a computer can prevent a malware attack
few of the popular antivirus software
are avast antivirus
not an antivirus and mcafee antivirus
secondly you should use firewalls a
firewall helps prevent and unauthorize
taxes
viruses and other malicious activities
that occur over the internet
as the name suggests it acts as a wall
between your system
and the internet it filters a traffic
that is allowed to enter your device
windows and mac os 10 have their default
built-in firewalls named as windows
firewall and mac firewall respectively
apart from this in order to prevent
attacks on your network
your router should also have a firewall
built in
[Music]
thirdly you should always stay alert and
avoid clicking on suspicious links
the links might look to be legitimate
but they can be home to malware which is
going to enter your system and cause a
havoc
lastly it is wise to update operating
systems and browsers regularly
if this is not done cyber criminals can
exploit these vulnerabilities and attack
your system
that was all about preventing a malware
attack
let's move on to the next attack it is
the phishing attack
it is one of the biggest widespread
types of cyber attacks
as per reports phishing accounts for
over 12 billion dollars in business
losses
so what is a phishing attack it is an
attack wherein
an attacker impersonates to be a trusted
contact and sends the victim fake emails
unaware of this the victim opens the
email and clicks on the malicious link
or opens the attachment in the mail the
aim of such an attack is to gain access
to confidential
information and account credentials
hackers can also install malware through
a phishing attack
this attack is growing bigger each day
as attackers are becoming more
convincing in pretending to be a trusted
source
for example you might get an email from
apple stating that your apple account is
kept on hold for security reasons
and the mail will ask you to type in
your login credentials in order to
restore your account
do not fall for that as it is a phishing
email
legitimate sources will not randomly
send you mails and ask for your account
credentials
phishing is a type of social engineering
attack social engineering attacks refer
to several malicious activities that are
obtained through human interactions
it manipulates the victim in such a way
that he or she ends up divulging
personal information such an attack can
happen on any platform such as
text messages or even on social media
sites
similar to phishing you also have voice
phishing known as
wishing wishing will be carried out over
a voice email or mobile phone or even
over landlines
so how do we prevent a phishing attack
human error is the reason for a high
percentage of cyber attacks
to prevent a phishing attack the wisest
way will be to scrutinize the emails you
receive
a phishing email will have some spelling
mistakes or a format change from that of
the legitimate source it is pretending
to come from
look for these loopholes and do not
click any sub-suspicious emails
next you can also make use of an
anti-phishing toolbar
sometimes when it is impossible to
identify a phishing email this toolbar
is helpful
it has a tool that provides you with
anti-phishing solutions
and information about the website you
are browsing
they prevent fraudulent websites from
masquerading as other legitimate
websites
for example avast online security is a
good anti-fishing toolbar you can get
you should also make it a habit to
update your passwords regularly
this way even if your own password is
known to a third party it will still be
invalid
let's now move on to the next type of
cyber attack
that is the password attack
this is a form of attack most of us
might have experienced at some point in
time
imagine when you try to log into an
account and it says incorrect password
in such a scenario it is possible that
an outsider has managed to either
guess or steal your password by doing so
all your data is compromised
a hacker can crack your password with
the help of various programs and
password cracking tools like aircrack
cane enable
john ripper hash cat and so on
there are different types of password
attacks a brute force attack
happens when the hacker tries to login
with all possible password combinations
meanwhile in the dictionary attack a
list of common passwords is used to
crack the user's login credentials
next is a keylogger attack keystroke
logging
records the keys struck on a keyboard by
the victim
and the victim is totally ignorant of
this this key logger or a keystroke
recorder can either be a hardware or a
software
speaking of how one can prevent password
attacks
it is crucial that you use alphanumeric
passwords which are strong
incorporate special characters in your
passwords as well
it is to be noted that you shouldn't be
using the same password for multiple
websites or accounts
also make sure to not use easily
guessable passwords which includes your
name or your family members names or
even your date of birth
needless to say update your passwords
regularly
this will limit your exposure to a
password attack
the next tip is something we should all
be careful about
often we make complicated passwords and
to remember them we noted down somewhere
or keeps them short of a password hint
in the open
this shouldn't be done in the open as
this can prove to be a gateway to an
attack
as a third party can misuse your account
with the help of
your password hint let's now move on and
have a look at the fourth type of cyber
attack on our list
that is the man in the middle attack as
you can see on your screens we have the
client on the left
the server on the right and the hacker
below
and now you can see that the client
server communication has been cut off
and instead the communication line now
goes through the hacker
so let's elaborate on this
man in the middle attack is also known
as eavesdropping attack
it takes place when an attacker comes in
between a two-party communication
in other words the attacker hijacks the
session between a client and host
so what do they gain by interrupting the
session well they are able to steal and
also filter data
imagine you are logging into your bank
account in such a state a man in the
middle attack can be used to obtain
information related to your bank account
let's now have a look at how we can
prevent man in the middle attack
firstly you should be aware of the
security of the website you are using
and it is advised to use
encryption on all devices that contain
crucial data
using an unsecure public wi-fi can help
attackers carry out the
man-in-the-middle attack
hence it is suggested that you avoid
using public wi-fi to carry out
important work next attack that we will
be talking about
is the sql injection attack
a structured query language sql
injection occurs in a database driven
website when the hacker manipulates a
standard sql query
this attack can be carried out by
submitting a malicious code into a
vulnerable website search box
thereby making the server reveal
information
the outcome of this attack is that the
attacker is able to view
edit and delete tables in the databases
in addition to this
the attackers can also obtain
administrator rights
an sql attack manipulates data and
accesses confidential information
in order to prevent a sql injection
attack you should use an intrusion
detection system
an ids is designed to detect
unauthorized access to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
this way unwanted requests can be
filtered out
the next step is to carry out a
validation of the user supplied data
there are codes that are developed to
identify illegal user inputs
the validation process helps in
verifying whether or not the type of
user input is allowed or not
this way only that value which passes
the validation will be processed
that was all about the sql injection
attack
so now that we have reached midway i'd
like to remind you all to feel free to
leave your questions in our chat section
and we will be happy to answer them
without further ado let's go back to our
list of the top cyber security threats
at number 6 we have the denial of
service attack
this is a type of attack that proves to
be a major threat to companies
in this attack malicious parties target
systems servers or networks and then
flood them with traffic so as to exhaust
their resources and bandwidth
as a result the server is unable to
handle incoming requests and thereby
resulting in the website it hosts to
either slow down or shut down
this leaves legitimate service requests
unattended
it is known as distributor denial of
service
ddos when attackers use multiple
compromise systems to launch this attack
like i mentioned earlier the ddos attack
is a major threat to organizations
let's have a look at one such ddos
attack
in february 2018 the famous united
states-based global company
github revealed that it was hit with a
distributed denial of service attack
ddos attack
this ddos attack is considered to be the
world's largest edos attack
as you might be aware github is a
developer platform used by millions all
over the world
hence it always has high traffic and
usage
but this time it wasn't just high
traffic but a whopping 1.35 terabits per
second
sending packets at a rate of 126.9
million
per second these figures speak for
itself
fortunately github was running a ddos
protection service which was
automatically alerted within 10 minutes
of the start of the attack
this attack only took github systems
down for about 15 to 20 minutes
github was able to stop the attack
quickly only because it utilized the
ddos
mitigation service that helped in
detecting the attack and which further
helped in quickly taking the necessary
steps to minimize the impact
let's now have a look at how to prevent
a ddos attack
firstly to stop a ddos attack you're
required to identify the malicious
traffic
this can be made possible by running a
traffic analysis
also remember to comprehend the warning
signs
few symptoms of a ddos attack include
network slowdown intermittent website
shutdowns etc
if anything seems irregular and unusual
then the organization should do the
needful
secondly understand that every
organization can face a ddos attack
and be ready with a prevention plan as
there won't be any time to prepare one
when it hits
for this purpose develop an incident
response plan have a checklist and make
sure your team and data center is
prepared
if you are well prepared you can tackle
a ddos attack smoothly like how github
did
lastly the conventional ddos mitigation
solutions oversize the network bandwidth
and require
complex hardware which proves to be
costly and also ineffective
whereas cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources
it is also to be noted that cloud-based
apps can absorb malicious traffic way
before it reaches its intended
destination
hence it is good to outsource ddos
prevention to cloud-based service
providers
that was all about the ddos attack
now let's look at number seven and here
we have the
insider threat
an insider threat as the name suggests
is one that does not involve a third
party
but an insider it could be someone from
the organization who knows everything
about the organization
it could be current employees former
employees contractors or even associates
these threats have the potential to
cause huge damages
researchers show that insider threats
are growing in small businesses
as employees have access to multiple
accounts that have a lot of data
the individuals who misuse this data can
put everyone else at risk
reasons for such security breaches are
many it can be due to malice greed or
even carelessness
such a threat is quite tricky as these
attacks are hard to predict
in order to prevent the insider threat
attack thorough preparation is required
organizations should make sure that they
have a good culture of security
awareness
businesses can limit the id resources a
user can have access to depending on
their job rules
this way the damage of cost can be
minimized
all the employees should be trained to
identify insider threats
and this way employees can understand
when an attacker has manipulated
or is attempting to misuse the company
data
next up in our list is cryptojacking
which is at number eight
i'm sure most of you are aware of the
word cryptocurrency
cryptojacking is related to
cryptocurrency you must be wondering how
let's understand what is crypto jacking
crypto jacking takes place when
attackers make their way into someone
else's computer to mine cryptocurrency
this is done by infecting a website or
by manipulating the victim to click on a
malicious link
which in turn loads crypto mining code
on the computer
it is also done through online ads with
javascript code that will auto execute
once loader in the victim's browser
victims are unaware of this
as the crypto mining code works in the
background the only sign they might
witness is a delay in the execution
crypto mining is a form of obtaining
cryptocurrency
crypto mining by itself is an immense
process that is the reason attackers
make use of other computers in order to
cryptomine
let's have a look at ways to prevent
crypto jacking it is advised that you
keep all security apps and software
updated to the latest versions as crypto
jacking can infect the most unprotected
systems
it is also good to have a crypto
tracking awareness training and give
tips to employees as to how to detect
crypto jacking threats
make sure to inform them about the risks
of opening emails from unknown senders
and clicking on attachments
ads are a primary source of
cryptojacking scripts
therefore it's good to install an ad
blocker and also have extensions like
minor blog which is
used to detect and block crypto mining
scripts
moving on to the number nine on our list
we have the zero day exploit
a zero day exploit occurs after the
announcement of a network vulnerability
usually the wenter becomes aware of a
vulnerability but a solution to it is
still not available for the same
hence the vendor announces the
vulnerability so that the users are
aware of it
but this also makes the attackers aware
of it
the vendor or the developer could take
any amount of time to find a solution
it could vary from a few hours to days
to months
depending on the vulnerability in the
meantime the attackers target the
disclose vulnerability
they exploit the vulnerability even
before a patch or a solution is
implemented
speaking of ways to prevent zero day
exploit organizations should have a
well-communicated patch management
process
it is also crucial to use management
solutions to automate the procedures
thus it avoids delays and deployment
having an incident response plan helps
in dealing with a cyber attack
you need to have a plan primarily
looking into zero-day attacks
in case of an attack this plan will keep
you prepared and will allow you to avoid
or reduce the damage
finally at number 10 we have the
watering hole attack
generally in a watering hole attack the
victim is of a specific group
it could be either victims of an
organization or a region or so
on here the attacker targets the
websites which are frequently used by
the particular group
they identify these websites either by
guesswork or by closely monitoring the
group
after which the attackers infect a few
of these websites with malware and
anyone who happens to visit the infected
website will have their computers
automatically loaded with malware
this attack loads the victim system with
malware similar to the phishing attack
the malware in such an attack targets
personal information of the victim
there is also a possibility that the
hacker will actively take control of the
infected computer
let's have a look at how we can prevent
the watering hole attack
just like most other cyber attack
prevention methods in this attack as
well it is strongly suggested that you
regularly update your software
by doing so you can reduce the risk of
this attack as this attack most often
exploits vulnerabilities also make sure
to regularly check for any security
patches
make use of your network security tools
to detect watering hole attacks
intrusion prevention systems work finely
when it comes to detecting a suspicious
act
similarly you can conduct regular
security checks using various network
security tools
to prevent a watering hole attack it is
good to conceal your online activities
this can be done with the help of a vpn
and also through your browser's private
browsing feature
a virtual private network often called a
vpn provides a secure connection to
another network
over the internet it acts as a cover to
your browsing activity
not vpn is an example of a vpn that can
be used to provide a secure connection
so those were all about the different
types of cyber threats
cyber security is implemented in order
to put a curve on these cyber attacks
cyber security refers to the practice of
protecting networks computer systems
and their components from unauthorized
digital access
according to the gartner forecast
worldwide it is stated that the
worldwide spending on cyber security is
forecasted to reach
133.7 billion dollars in 2022
and according to the university of
maryland hackers attack
every 39 seconds that is on an average
2244 times a day
although we had a look at multiple
methods to prevent a cyber attack
let's once again have a look at a few
personal tips and ways in which you can
prevent a cyber attack on the whole
firstly it is important you change your
passwords regularly and not only change
but use strong passwords that are
difficult to crack
do not have extremely complicated
passwords that you would tend to forget
rather use a password with at least
eight characters and preferably
alphanumeric
also keep in mind not to use the same
password twice
next update both the operating system
and applications
this will remove vulnerabilities that
hackers tend to exploit
make use of antivirus protection
software as they prevent
malware and other viruses from entering
into your device
use antivirus software from trusted and
legitimate vendors only
make sure to use a firewall as it will
filter the traffic entering your device
use other network security tools such as
intrusion prevention systems access
control application security and so on
fourthly as mentioned in the earlier
section don't open emails from unknown
centers
scrutinize the emails that you receive
and see where it comes from and if there
are any grammatical or format errors
ideally it is good to make use of a vpn
by doing so the traffic is encrypted
between the vpn server and your device
this proves to be a protection for your
device
the next step is that you regularly
backup your data
according to many security professionals
it is good to have three copies of your
data
on two different types of media and one
copy in an
offsite location like a cloud storage
this way even if you witness a cyber
attack you can erase your systems and
restore with a recently performed backup
up next is that you should train your
employees inside the security principles
they should also be aware of the various
cyber threats and know how to tackle
them in case of any emergency
the next one is a crucial step and that
is to make sure to use two-factor or
multi-factor authentication
normally while logging in you would
enter your user id and password
but with two-factor authentication users
are required to provide two different
authentication factors to verify
themselves
it could be an additional personal
identification code or maybe even a
fingerprint
when you are asked for more than two
additional authentication methods apart
from your username and password it is
termed as
a multi-factor authentication thus it
proves to be a better step to secure
your account
make sure to always secure your wi-fi
networks
the next point is that refrain from
using public wi-fi without using a
virtual private network that is a vpn
finally it is also necessary that you
safeguard your mobile
as mobiles are also a cyber attack
target
for this purpose install apps from only
trusted and legitimate sources
make sure to keep your device updated
and there you go those were a few of the
cyber security tips and ways to prevent
a cyber attack
so we are now done looking at the top 10
cyber threats and the ways to prevent
these cyber attacks
with that we have reached the end of
this video do you agree with our list
think we missed anything important let
us know in the comment section below
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here